so what's the plan once the film is
finished what's your plan for it well
it's sort of an ongoing process I guess
determining what the best route is
there's so many opportunities these days
with the internet on self distribution
and so we feel really comfortable about
doing that and that's sort of our backup
in the long term in the shorts when we'd
like to submit it to film festivals and
we've had actually some interest from
different television stations mostly in
Europe actually but so we think that
there are some interest out there to
potentially do some sort of more of a
traditional type of release and so we're
not we're not a hundred percent sure but
we might like to go that route and so
we're sort of yeah I don't know where
first or not I feel like I've actually
learned a lot about the sort of DIY
distribution actually from reading your
blog and watching a lot of your
interviews from different filmmakers you
know people will mention a different you
know downloadable site or you know
different options and I'll kind of write
them down and and so I think but one of
the the pros of maybe going with more
traditional distribution if that's an
option is just the ability to kind of
reach more people outside of the
communities that are already interested
in this you know we feel like if we were
to do distribution ourself we could
probably do a pretty good job of
reaching people already interested in
tiny houses and already interested in
kind of design and sustainability and
kind of these areas that are thrown
touches on but but we would have a
better chance of maybe reaching you know
the random person who's never thought
about this before if we were to go
through a more kind of mainstream
traditional route so what kind of what
we're yeah talking about
going basis yeah definitely and you know
because we were able you know you'd be
pretty much fun that putted it all
ourselves or through Kickstarter it
actually gives us quite a lot of
latitude in what we can choose to do
with it when we're done which is really
nice and sort of freeing yeah so I mean
we've we've also been pretty selling
DVDs on our website which has been great
but also some adds pressure to to get it
finished so but we know that there's
interest because of that so
you